[Music]
thank you for agreeing to talk to us
there's a story that's going to be told
and I would rather be the one telling it
Jill Dillard sits down for a documentary
about her embattled family
this is much bigger than the Duggars one
year after her brother Josh Duggar began
his 12-year prison sentence The
Institute raises little Predators
breaking news a dark Family secret is
exposed it's like the epitome of evil
breaks my heart to think about the girls
the former reality star appears in the
trailer for the upcoming docu-series
Shiny Happy People Duggar family secrets
world domination was the goal if you
drop June 2nd on Prime video
TLC created a PR show for gothard's
teachings you've probably heard of the
Duggar family everyone knew who the
family was Jill has rarely spoken about
the downfall of her family we're
actually doubling the amount of
grandkids in one year who were made
famous by the reality series 19 Kids and
Counting we we did the best that we knew
how at that point and we've learned some
things then Michelle Duggar the family
matriarch speaking with Megan Kelly When
the show was abruptly canceled in 2015
after the Revelation that Josh sexually
assaulted multiple young women one of
them being Jill yes we I think as
parents you feel like a failure when one
of your kids does something wrong but
the truth is that kids will make their
own choices and they will make their own
decisions when you're addressing your
brother's crimes do you think anyone had
any idea that he was living a lie was
there something in you that was like
this just doesn't seem right I can't say
like oh I saw this coming because I
don't think anybody did in 2021 more
disturbing news Josh was convicted on
two counts related to child pornography
and surrendered to a Texas federal
prison in June to start serving a nearly
13-year prison sentence I'm grateful
that he is in that place that Justice is
being served and I think that that is
the best way that I can love at this
point to pray and ask God to do the work
that only he can do in his heart the
iblp teachings aren't Christianity
there's something entirely different
iblp iblp ibop what's it stand for The
Institute in basic life principles we
were part of iblp as early as I can
remember the biggest feature of Bill
gothard's teachings is Authority kids
obey the parents lives obey their
husbands for the first time Jill is
going on the record about her family's
devout religious organization the real
story is a much bigger one
now is the time there's a story that's
going to be told and I would rather be
the one telling it